hello thank you for being here good
afternoon slash
evening nearly uh my name is shahid
abari and i'm your chair
um i don't mean to smear the good name
of our many panelists
but i'm thinking of re-titling this
debate the limits of prosecco enabled
logic and bitchings has already taken
her wellies off
uh simon's promise that he's like coming
off
um but the description for this talk as
you may have seen is that logicians
don't rule the world
or get the most done so i might disagree
could it be that a consistent world view
is neither desirable
nor achievable if we abandon the
straitjacket of rationality
might this lead to a more powerful and
exciting future or is it a heresy
that leads to madness each speaker will
have four minutes
and then i will ask a couple of
questions and we will turn out to you as
soon as possible
um and our speakers are on my right ian
mcgill christ author of the master and
his mystery
the divided brain and the making of the
modern world and he's also the former
consultant psychiatrist at the battle
memorial hospital and he contributes to
the bmj the sunday times
and the tls is that right
simon blackburn cambridge philosopher
and vice president of
the british humanist association his
books include truth
ruling passions and his latest is mirror
mirror uses and
abuses of self-love published by
princeton and bitter example on my left
socialist
and feminist activist and writer she's
written for the guardian
new statesman and red rag and is the
author of nine books
including this year's the end of
equality i'm going to kick
us off with ian is a consistent and
logical worldview
neither desirable nor achievable
i think it's no criticism of something
to say that it has its
place it has its uses it has its
extremely
important values but it can't deal with
everything
um anybody who thinks that the same kind
of
logic that works well in the courtroom
works well in the bedroom is in for a
bit of a surprise
and we don't always need to view things
in quite the same way in fact
logic can only answer or help us to
answer
um it's a tool which will help us to
answer certain kinds of questions
above all this is a tool for consistency
and one of the problems
is that not all truths are
self-consistent
it is one of the founding beliefs of the
western tradition that they are
but it is certainly not a belief in any
other tradition
and the difficulty with that is that a
wise
humane understanding of life involves
balancing a kind of rational processing
with the fruits of experience and
with things that are guided by
intuition which is not in itself
something sort of vague and random but
something that is also schooled by
experience and people who reason well
use intuition
better what worries me is that we may be
moving into a world where
only a sort of rationalizing
is acceptable in many languages there
are two words actually or at least two
words
for what we encompass by re the word
reason
for example in german they differentiate
between foshtant which is the sort of
processing
according to principles and rules such
as a computer could do and for nonft
which is
the product of uh wise experience
so i think these things are reason is
terribly important but it has its place
it can't ground our knowledge of reality
and it can't interpret it at the top end
but it can at the intermediary level
ensure consistency that's what it does
it shouldn't be mistaken for being able
to answer ultimate questions
because you can't reason towards the
principles from which you begin to
reason
or towards how you understand them nor
indeed can you reason towards the value
of reason itself
we ensure that reason is valuable so
it has its place and it's very important
to remember that sometimes
truths may not be compatible
inconsistency is and i think ian has
in fact conceded this um inconsistency
is in general a bad thing if i tell you
shut the window and
don't shut the window um you're puzzled
you you don't know what i've said
there's no way of obeying my command i
am given a command actually
why not because it's logically
impossible that you should shut the
window and not shut the window
so as ian rightly says consistency
matters i'm not sure what he means he
says not all truths
are consistent it seems to me that if
you find
a set of axioms or principles that
deliver an inconsistency they deliver
that something is so
and it's not so then you've got
something wrong there's something wrong
it's the
that's the logical form known as
reductio ad absurdum and it's very
important in mathematics and geometry
in all kinds of deductively uh settled
and
precise sciences that if you find that
your principles give you a contradiction
then you
your principles need revision they need
you need to go back on them
because it's like issuing an order shut
the window and don't shut the window
that's a bad order
so it is very important now of course
people sometimes use words like
rationality and logic as though they
have a sort of hegemonic you know
sovereignty over all our thought
processes
and that's certainly not true we learn
from experience for example a logic book
will not tell you
um you know how to cultivate your grass
uh if you want to know how to cultivate
a grass you go to a hot culture book if
you want to know how to
raise a cow you go to your book about
farming uh you don't go to
um the great logicians you don't go to
aristotle you don't go to
russell you don't go to godel
to tarski but if you want to know how to
write a computer program
that doesn't just deliver junk then
logic is very important
and you better pay attention to it
because otherwise you will get junk
the problem with the junk program an
inconsistent program is that it will
deliver anything um the most logical
systems you can derive anything from a
contradiction
and so if you've got inconsistency in
your program you've got junk
and it's been very very important
throughout the 20th and 21st century
for programmers for example to know when
they
when they've got consistency one of the
great marvelous
discoveries of modern logic uh girdle's
theorem
uh in effect when computing comes to
saying that you can't actually prove the
consistency of a program except by using
a stronger program
so computer scientists are always as it
were
at the limit of knowing that their
programs are as they should be
and these are fantastic results logic is
a science
a science of consistency and to do it
properly you need formal languages you
need a lot of mathematics
but if you don't do properly as i say
you get junk
now as far as rationality goes
of course you know we have intuition we
have experience we have
hunches you know the experienced
detective has his hunch that so-and-so
was a
criminal and he may be right um that's
absolutely fine logic has nothing
whatever to say against
those methods uh it's an empirical
question whether they work or not it's
an empirical question whether the
detectives hunches pay off or not
uh logic is silent um it's not a
it's not logic doesn't give you a
process of discovery
uh all it gives you is a check
on whether the things you think you've
discovered hang together or not
um now i think that if ian and i are
going to disagree it's about his idea
that truths don't have to hang together
i think they do i think you need a
consistent world view
and if you don't have it then you're
you risk again just falling into
a sort of abyss in which anything goes
and that's fatal
my problem with the question is i don't
know what it means
i don't know how to talk about it and
um
and i do in a sense i don't know what
it's getting at except
of course i can see the logic and the
consistency
imperative within the discourses that
both of you
are concerned with and both of you
occupy i come at the question
if you like from a different trajectory
not as a professional thinking person
well a professional writing person
but when i was trying to try to find a
way of entering this
conversation in my imagination before we
were having it
i was thinking right what do i think and
i
and i recalled a marvelous
section in an essay by susan bordeaux
who's an american political philosopher
who writes about feminism
and bodies and philosophy and stuff
she wrote a lovely essay on foucault and
uh and she tells us in the essay that
she
found herself taken by surprise
by herself thank you all can you join me
in finding our speakers
[Applause]